china condenó a Estados Unidos por
derribar su globo y describió la
respuesta como una reacción exagerada y
una grave violación de las prácticas
internacionales también amenazó con
tomar medidas en respuesta el ejército
estadounidense destruyó el globo chino
frente a la costa de Carolina del sur
este sábado una semana después de que el
objeto entrara en su espacio aéreo
el miércoles cuando fue informado sobre
el globo le ordené al Pentágono que lo
derribara Tan pronto como fuera posible
para no causar ningún daño en tierra
decidieron que la mejor manera era
hacerlo en el agua tuvieron éxito lo
derribaron y Quiero felicitar a los
pilotos que lo hicieron
[Música]
Washington asegura que el globo era
utilizado por China para espiar sitios
estratégicos en Estados Unidos de hecho
fue detectado sobrevolando puntos
militares por su parte Beijing afirma
que se trata de una aeronave civil
investigación meteorológica que se
desvió de su ruta por el viento sin
embargo otro objeto similar fue visto en
América Latina como informó la fuerza
aérea colombiana el día 3 de febrero de
2023 en horas de la mañana el sistema de
defensa aérea nacional detectó un objeto
sobre los 55.000 pies de altura que
ingresó al espacio aéreo colombiano en
el sector Norte del país movilizándose a
una velocidad promedio de unos 25 nudos
identificándose en el características
similares a las de un globo el globo es
similar al que sobrevoló Estados Unidos
y habría sido visto también en Costa
Rica sin embargo no se ha confirmado si
es un globo de vigilancia chino